welcome to the presentation on finding
the equation of a line
let's get started say i had two points i
said the point
one comma two
and i had the point three comma four and
i want to figure out the equation of the
line through these points so let's let's
at least figure out what that line looks
like
so 1
comma 2
is here
and 2
three four
three comma four is here
and if i want to draw a line
a line through them it'll look something
like that
what we want to do is figure out the
equation of this line well we know that
the
the form of an equation of a line is y
equals m
x
plus b
where m is the slope
slope and that tells you how steep the
line is and b is the y-intercept and i
don't know why people chose m and b
we'll have to do some research on that b
is the y-intercept and the y-intercept
is just where does it intersect the
y-axis
so let's get and this problem is you
could actually look at it figure it out
but let's do it mathematically
so the equation for the slope m
it's rise
over run another way to view that is for
any amount that you run
along the x-axis how much do you rise
well let's do that numerically rise is
the same thing as change over y
and run is the same thing as change over
x delta this triangle means change
change in y
well change in y let's let's take the
starting point to be three comma four
let's say we're going from three comma
four to two comma one the change in y
is four minus two we just took this four
minus this 2
over
minus 1.
my phone was ringing out let me let me
lower the volume over 3 minus 1
and that's just this three minus this
one so if we just solve for it we get
four minus two is two
and three minus one is also two so we
get the slope is equal to one and that
makes sense because when we move over 1
and x we go up exactly 1 in y when we
move to the left 1 in x we move down
exactly 1 in y
so now we know the equation is y
equals one x
plus b because we solved that m equals
one
and this is of course the same thing as
y
equals x plus b
now all we have left to do is solve for
b
well how do we do that because because
we we have three variables here well we
could actually substitute
one of these pairs of points in for y
and x that makes sense because
these points have to satisfy this
equation so let's take this first pair y
is equal to 2
2 is equal to x which is 1 plus b
it's pretty easy equation to solve we
get b
equals 1. so that tells us that the
equation of this line is y
equals x
plus one that's pretty straightforward
equation it makes sense the y intercept
is one which is exactly here zero comma
one
and the slope is one and that's pretty
obvious for every amount that we move to
the right we move the same amount up
so the slope is 1. let's do another
problem
let's say i wanted to find the equation
of the line between the points
negative 3
comma 5
and
two comma negative six
well we do the same thing
m is equal to change in y
over change in x
so let's let's take this as a starting
point
so let's say negative 6
minus 5. so we just took negative 6
minus 5
over
minus
negative 3.
you got to be real careful to get the
signs right so it's 2
minus negative 3
negative 6 minus 5 is minus 11
and 2 minus negative 3 well that's the
same thing as 2 plus plus 3 so that's 5.
so we have the slope is equal to
negative 11 over 5.
and notice that if we if
on on the numerator we use negative 6 as
a starting point that in the denominator
we have to use 2 as a starting point
we could have done it the other way
around we could have said
minus negative 6
over
negative 3 minus 2 in which case we've
forgotten
this would have been 11
over negative 5. so as long as you if
you use
the negative 6 first you have to use the
2 first or if you use the 5 first and
you have to use the negative 3 first i
hope i'm not completely confusing you
guys well anyway we know the slope is
negative 11 fifths
so the equation of this line so far is y
equals minus 11 over 5
x plus b
now we can take one of these pairs on
the top and substitute back and solve
for b
let's take the first pair
so 5 is y so we say 5
equals
negative 3 so it's negative 11 over 5
times negative 3
right i just put the x in for x plus b
so just simplifying that i get 5 is
equal to 33
over 5 plus b
or b is equal to
minus 33
over 5
on this equals 25
minus 33
over 5.
25 minus 33 is minus 8
so the equation of this line and this
one wasn't as clean as the other one
obviously is let me do another color for
emphasis
y
equals
minus 11
over five
x
minus
eight over five
hopefully that those two examples will
give you enough of an idea to uh do the
the figuring out the equation of a line
problems and if you have problems with
this you might just want to
try just the slope of the line problems
or the y-intercept problems separately i
hope you have fun
bye